[Applaudissements]
220 000 américains morts
si vous n'entendez rien d'autre je dis ce soir
entendez ceci
quiconque est responsable de ne pas prendre le
contrôle
en fait ne dis pas que je suis je ne prends aucune
responsabilité au départ
quiconque est responsable de tant de
morts ne devrait pas rester président de
la  États-Unis d'Amérique
mais vous receviez beaucoup d'argent de la
Russie, ils vous payaient beaucoup d'
argent
et ils le sont probablement encore, mais maintenant avec
ce qui est sorti aujourd'hui,
c'est encore pire tous les e-
mails les e-mails les e-mails horribles du genre
de  l'argent que vous récoltiez en vous et
votre famille
et joe vous étiez vice-président quand
certains de ces événements se produisaient
et cela n'aurait jamais dû arriver et je
pense que vous devez une
explication au peuple américain je
n'ai jamais
pris un sou d'aucune source étrangère
dans ma vie, nous avons appris que ce
président payait
50 fois l'impôt en chine avait un
compte bancaire secret
avec la chine fait des affaires en chine
et en fait parle de moi prenant de l'
argent
parents  ont été arrachés leurs enfants ont été
arrachés de leurs bras
et séparés et maintenant ils ne peuvent pas trouver
plus de 500
ensembles de ces parents et ces enfants ne sont
seuls
nulle part où aller nulle part où aller c'est
criminel
c'est criminel je leur ai demandé il y a une semaine j'ai
dit
ce que j'ai payé  ils ont dit monsieur, vous avez prépayé des
dizaines de millions de dollars, j'ai prépayé mes
impôts au cours des
dernières années, des dizaines de millions de
dollars que j'ai prépayés
parce qu'à un moment donné, ils pensent que c'est une
estimation, ils pensent que je devrai peut-être payer des
impôts,
donc je l'ai déjà prépayé  personne ne m'a dit
que vous savez quelle corée du nord
nous ne sommes pas en guerre nous avons de bonnes
relations vous savez que les gens ne
comprennent pas avoir de bonnes relations
avec les dirigeants d'un autre
homme nous avions de bonnes relations avec
hitler avant qu'il n'envahisse l'
europe  le reste de l'europe allez ce
qu'il a fait
il a légitimé la corée du nord il a parlé
de son bon copain qui est un voyou
un voyou et il parle de la façon dont nous sommes
mieux et ils ont des missiles beaucoup plus
capables
ab  le pour atteindre le territoire américain beaucoup plus
facilement que jamais auparavant, laissez-moi
suivre
ce que je voudrais faire, c'est de bien meilleurs
soins de santé, bien
mieux protégera toujours les personnes atteintes de maladies
préexistantes, donc j'aimerais résilier
obamacare créer une marque  de nouveaux
beaux soins de santé,
les démocrates le feront parce
qu'il y aura une pression énorme sur eux
et nous pourrions même avoir la maison à ce
moment-là
et je pense que nous allons gagner la maison d'
accord, vous verrez mais je pense que nous sommes
va gagner la maison
personne n'a fait plus pour la communauté noire
que donald trump et si vous regardez à
l'exception
d'abraham lincoln exception possible
mais l'exception d'abraham
lincoln personne n'a fait ce que j'ai fait
la réforme de la justice pénale obama et
joe l'ont fait '  ne le faites pas abraham lincoln ici est l'
un des présidents les plus racistes que nous ayons
eu dans l'histoire moderne,
il verse du carburant sur
chaque feu raciste chacun qu'il a
commencé sa campagne en descendant l'
escalator en disant qu'il se débarrasse de
t  tuyau
violeurs mexicains il a interdit les musulmans
parce qu'ils sont musulmans
il s'est déplacé et a tout
aggravé à
tous les niveaux